marseille élections législatives à
refaire le duel bernard tapie guy
teissier ne passionne plus les poules
abstention relativement importante au
premier tour roumanie le président
chaouch et secoue son épouse dirige le
pays d'une main de fer et l'entraînent
vers la ruine économique rasante au
passage des vestiges de son passé
historique
un document exceptionnel dans ce journal
au québec le chanteur renaud fait un
tabac nos cousins comprennent très bien
son français qui n'est pourtant pas
celui de la belle province
un renault plein d'humour un reportage
avec l'accent à la fin de cette édition
madame monsieur bonjour le temps passe
et bonsoir plus exactement le temps
passe et les choses ne sont plus jamais
ce qu'elles ont été sur la canebière à
marseille aujourd'hui le duel super
tapis contre guy teissier qui avait
passionné les foules en juin dernier n'a
pas fait recette
un nombre important d'abstention dans
cette élection législative partielle
après l'annulation de l'élection du rpr
guy teissier qui n'avait battu que de
quelques voix l'industriel bernard tapie
a marseille tout de suite nous
rejoignons patrice voler l'eau et
jacqueline épouse derrier taux zéro de
trop à risque
il a changé de casquette guy teissier le
candidat laisse place à guy teissier
maire de secteur est président d'un
bureau comme lui hyacinthe santoni
conseiller municipal et candidat car
aujourd'hui à marseille
chacun des 60 bureaux était tenue par un
élu municipal
personne ne devrait renouer avec la
fraude mauvais souvenir de l'élection de
juin élection partielle sous le signe la
transparence donc et pourtant faible
mobilisation de l'électorat 14 15% à
12h40 de 5 à 17 heures en comparaison au
premier tour en juin dernier
65% des électeurs s'étaient rendus aux
urnes une partielle sans enjeu national
et la seule perspective de municipal
agité sur le vieux port n'a pas suffi à
rendre aux marseillais leur ardeur
électorale
c'est pareil
j'attends j'attends ce que j'attends
depuis toujours c'est-à-dire pas
grand-chose savez c'est les promesses
sont bien gentils mais je peux rien
d'aller voter
j'ai mes idées je veux voter par 10 par
dj d'évoquer c'est important et puis je
le chope pourtant beauty
toute la journée les candidats ont fait
le tour des bureaux histoire de sentir
la tendance
et pourquoi pas de convaincre les
abstentionnistes ou les derniers indécis
mais c'est d'ici que sortira le verdict
des urnes dépouillement sous haute
surveillance depuis 18 heures première
tendance fléchissement du front national
et maintien du vote communiste
voilà donc vous comprenez les résultats
sont longs à venir étant donné la haute
surveillance de ce scrutin
peut-être les résultats dans le courant
de ce journal en tout cas dans la
dernière édition qui vous sera présenté
tout à l'heure par philippe gassot
deuxième sujet de l'actualité la sphère
pechiney un dimanche sans nouvelles
révélations mais avec plusieurs
réactions politiques virulentes de
l'opposition que nous écouterons dans un
instant l'occasion aussi de faire le
point sur la dernière information en
date publiée par le journal le monde
d'hier après-midi l'acquisition n'ont
plus de 10000 mais de 50 mille actions
de la société américaine rachetée par la
société française pechiney par roger
patrice pelât ami proche très proche
même du président de la république qui
deviendrait ainsi un des acteurs
principaux de cette affaire mais
rappelons le encore l'information est à
prendre au conditionnel et en attendant
la sortie officielle du rapport de la
commission des opérations de bourse
toujours prévue pour le 31 janvier elle
sera difficile à vérifier cette
information dans la mesure où monsieur
poulat est un homme très discret
compagnons de captivité de résistance du
président de la république c'est un
industriel difficile à classer
politiquement mais dont l'amitié avec
monsieur mitterrand ne s'est jamais
démenti roger patrice pelât un homme
discret au point que l'on ne possède que
très peu d'image de lui et encore moins
de paroles ans
istres et françoise joly pascal guy
roger patrice pelât l'un des tout
premiers noms côté français à avoir été
cité dans la sphère pechiney mi-décembre
le journal l'express révèle que patrice
pelât acheté dix mille actions de la
société triangle 1h à exécuter à paris
en son propre nom mais voilà dans une
période critique
quelques jours avant la transaction
officielle entre pechiney les américains
un sacré coup financier réalisé grâce à
un de ses amis
max théret l'ancien président de la fnac
qui a également acheté des actions et
qui affirme tout simplement avoir eu du
flair ni lui ni patrice pelât dit ils
n'ont bénéficié d'informations
privilégiées
meyer nouvelles révélations du journal
le monde
patrice pelât aurait en fait acheté non
pas dix mille mais cinquante mille
actions après un deuxième achat beaucoup
plus discret en suisse patrice pelât se
retrouve donc ce soir sous les
projecteurs car également très proche du
président de la république françois
mitterrand et roger patrice pelât marche
du même pas depuis plus de 45 ans au
panthéon en 1980 dans les premiers rangs
plus qu'un ami pour le nouveau président
un intime et il aime par exemple lorsque
je promène dans paris s'est avancé
émission c'est chad est temps de parler
des choses à la lie une amitié nourrit
de souvenirs nés en captivité dans un
stalag quelque part en allemagne
combattants des brigades internationales
pendant la guerre d'espagne
patrice pelât deviendra le supérieur
hiérarchique de françois mitterrand dans
la résistance
les deux hommes depuis lors ne se sont
jamais perdus de vue
mais si françois mitterrand choisit très
vite la politique pour en gravir
finalement tous les échelons
son compagnon de route lui se contentera
de mandats plus modestes nerfs de
boutigny sur essonne une petite commune
de la région parisienne puis conseiller
général de la fierté allait jusqu'en 82
patrice pelât reste avant tout un chef
d'entreprise à la tête de vie brachotte
spécialisée dans la sous traitance de
matériel électronique
monsieur paul a négocié des contrats
internationaux gagne de l'argent puis
revend son entreprise à alstom et
regagne de l'argent dans la sphère
depuis sa mise en cause par le journal
le monde
hier patrice pelât se fait encore plus
discret que d'habitude à son domicile
parisien
personne le téléphone reste aussi sourd
que la porte est close en sologne à
quelques kilomètres de la
ferté-saint-aubin cette demeure de m un
château louis xiii perdu au milieu
d'hectares et d'hectares de forêt
témoigne de la réussite professionnelle
de roger patrice pelât
mais monsieur peu là évidemment n'est
pas là enfin dans la sphère pechiney
reste toujours ces questions concernant
la filière suisse
celle par qui est passé le plus gros
volume d'actions mais l'a pour l'instant
on ne sait toujours pas qui a donné
l'ordre d'achat de ces titres
réactions politiques sur cette affaire
ce soir l'opposition attaque très fort
après avoir moduler ses attaques durant
la semaine dernière sur rtl d'abord
réaction d'alain juppé secrétaire
général du rpr qui considèrent que
l'image de françois mitterrand est
assurément éclaboussé par les affaires
suivies d'une métaphore en forme de
jugement sur les socialistes que je lui
laisse le soin de vous livrer monsieur
juppé on avait l'habitude de dire ça
n'était pas mon opinion mais beaucoup
d'observateurs le disait que la france
avait la droite la plus bête du monde
je me demande si les socialistes ne sont
pas en train d'apporter la démonstration
qu'elle à la gauche la plus pourrie du
monde
monsieur bérégovoy seraient bien
inspirés s'ils s'engageaient devant les
français nous avons des procédures de
coopération avec les américains à
coopérer avec la sec et à publier très
officiellement le rapport de la sec
nous sommes en sort et monsieur michel
noir espèrent encore maintenant sur
europe 1 ce soir
mais monsieur noir veut une commission
denquête on les écoute j'ai mal un peu à
la france quand je vois tous les jours à
la une war en page en allemand ou du
boston globe tous les jours tous les
jours l'image la france comme étant le
pays des affaires ça ça me fait mal pour
sortir de ce climat malsain et pour
éviter qu'il y ait justement ces
amalgames entre eux à faire et pouvoir
politique
je fais la proposition michel michel
rocard premier ministre la pierre
bérégovoy mise des finances
sont ils prêts à accepter la proposition
de création de commission denquête que
je ferais jeudi prochain en commission
des finances
lors de l'audition de monsieur pierre
bérégovoy s'il accepte je crois que tous
les français les croiront lorsqu'ils
disent qu'ils veulent toute la vérité
dans cette affaire un autre bord
politique maintenant monsieur andré
lajoinie du parti communiste au forum
rmc fr 3 il s'indigne de ces milliards
qui dit il passe au dessus de la tête
des salariés et demande lui aussi la
mise sur pied d'une commission d'
enquête parlementaire monsieur lajoinie
au moment on refuse ça c'est ça le
scandale le plus grand au moment où on
refuse les revendications légitimes des
gens des salariés qui demandent le smig
à 6000 francs une augmentation des
salaires dans la fonction publique
l' éducation nationale à la santé et à
hyères et bien voilà les milliards valls
les milliards public leur manière à eux
valls au dessus de leur tête et bien moi
je dis il ne faut pas étouffer cela
c'est pour ça que je demande une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire qui a
droit à cette mission là même si ces
commissions d'un gars devraient avoir
mon avis plus de pouvoir enfin telles
qu'elles sont elles ont du pouvoir
elles doivent contribuer avec la sec
américaine avec la coop a fait à la
clarté et surtout et surtout parce que
la clarté sera fait faire que les
responsables quels qu'ils soient et à
quelque niveau qu'ils soient soient
poursuivis en justice et soient punis
enfin monsieur françois d'aubert vice
président de l'udf interrogé sur radio
pacifique fm trouve invraisemblable
qu'un ministre de la vème république ne
couvre pas ses collaborateurs tout en
reprochant à monsieur boublil directeur
démissionnaire du cabinet du ministre
des finances monsieur bérégovoy de
s'être dit il entre 1981 et 1984 alors
qu'il était en poste à l'élysée amusé
avec les filiales des grands groupes
français comme on joue au monopoly
considérant les dirigeants de ces
entreprises comme des pions sur un jeu
d'échecs une autre affaire d'ailleurs
intérêt ce monsieur d'aubert le rachat
de la société de cinéma pathé monsieur
d'aubert affirme que le crédit lyonnais
banques nationalisées française a donné
des instructions à sa filière sa filiale
hollandaise pour prêter de l'argent à un
homme d'affaires italien monsieur pareti
déjà condamné par la justice
afin de participer au rachat de pa té en
collaboration avec un homme d'affaires
français proche de l'elysée lui aussi
max théret dont on a déjà parlé ce soir
et qui selon monsieur d'aubert ne
seraient peut-être dans cette affaire
qu'un homme de paille en dehors des
affaires proprement dite dans la
perspective des élections municipales le
front national a adopté aujourd'hui une
charte visant à réduire l'immigration en
particulier dans les banlieues où elle a
été concentrée dit monsieur le pen
le texte demande également que la
préférence nationale soit établie dans
l'accès au logement hlm et à l'aide
sociale enfin le front national veut
également que la démocratie directe
c'est-à-dire le référendum au niveau
local soit développe la politique
étrangère en commençant par la roumanie
à deux heures d'avion de paris ce pays
d'europe de l'est riverains de la mer
noire vite actuellement un drame
depuis plusieurs années en effet
maintenant le chef de l'état et son
épouse qu'il ce qui le seconde monsieur
et madame ceausescu dilapide le
potentiel économique de ce pays pourtant
très important en appliquant par exemple
par la force une politique qui aboutit à
la ruine du pays sur tous les plans y
compris son histoire ce document vous
sera présentée dans son intégralité
jeudi soir dans le magazine résistance
sur antenne 2 jacques violet résumé de
ceux des pubs
images de misère et de pénurie visage
d'un peuple qui vit sous la terreur la
peur la violence et la torture morale
aujourd'hui en roumanie
on a faim les principales préoccupations
se nourrir se chauffer se vêtir les
seuls magasins qui existent les magasins
d'état sont vides et chaque arrivage
entraîne d'incroyables files d'attentes
cette situation de crise est imposé à la
population par son guide
nicolas ceausescu le comte doute à tort
et comme on l'appelle au pouvoir depuis
en 83 au nom de l'indépendance nationale
il décide de rembourser d'un seul coup
la dette de la roumanie dix milliards de
dollars
les roumains doit se sacrifier toute la
production de viande de légumes est
exporté vers l'étranger bucarest
n'importe pratiquement rien
chaque roumain n'a droit qu'à cinq cents
grammes de viande par mois le pain de
sucre l'huile tout est strictement
rationner les vieux ne sont plus soignés
après 70 ans la mortalité infantile est
telle que les naissances ne sont prises
en compte qu'après un mois
l'agriculture et collectiviser ont
détruit des villages entiers et long des
portes les paysans le dictateur entourée
de sa famille instaure le national
communisme dynastique
il veut créer un homme nouveau celui qui
n'aura pas de passer la folie des
grandeurs la mégalomanie n'a pas de
limites sur les ruines de ce qui fut le
bucarest historique touché ce coup fait
construire un palais et un boulevard du
triomphe du socialisme le peuple roumain
lui vit le goulag au quotidien même le
grand père soviétique trouve que la
roumanie n'est plus présentable paula
une deux événements aujourd'hui le
syndicat solidarité accepte
officiellement une table ronde avec le
gouvernement d'autre part l'archevêché
de varsovie a confirmé qu'un prêtre
proche des milieux de l'opposition
politique au gouvernement du général
josé ce qui avait été assassiné ce qui
n'est pas sans rappeler la sphère du
père popieluszko opposants lui aussi qui
avait été abattu par la police secrète
isabel peichert voici le père stéphane
dj halak il ya quelques mois au milieu
d'un rassemblement de responsables
solidarité âgé de 74 ans il était un des
membres notoires de l'opposition
polonaise
depuis quelques jours il était inquiet
il aurait même dit à quelques proches
qui n'avaient pas pris au sérieux son
angoisse qu'il redoutait qu'on le tue
son sacristain l'a trouvé ce matin dans
la cuisine de son appartement gisant
dans une mare de sang le crâne enfoncé
l'appartement était mise
de l'argenterie avait disparu mais pas
l'argent liquide ce qui fait penser à un
meurtre maquillé en cambriolage
ce matin le père ni jahlav devait
prononcer une messe à la mémoire de
polonais mort en 1863 en luttant contre
l'occupation russe dans l'entourage de
solidarité cet assassinat étrange fait
bien sûr penser à une provocation
destinée à saboter les négociations
entre le syndicat interdit depuis 81 et
le pouvoir au pays basque espagnol une
manifestation monstre à marquer à bilbao
la fin des quinze jours de trêve des
attentats décidée unilatéralement par
les terroristes de le taire reste à
savoir maintenant si le gouvernement
central de madrid va faire un geste ou
si le cycle de la violence va reprend
marc maisonneuve
philippe etcheverry à bilbao dans la
nuit de samedi à dimanche quarante mille
manifestants selon la police
cent mille selon les organisateurs sont
descendues dans la rue répondant à
l'appel d'éric batasuna organisation
proche de letea les manifestants ont un
double objectif la reprise des
négociations entre l'organisation
séparatiste et le gouvernement espagnol
et l'annoncent de la fin d'une trêve de
15 jours
la trêve des attentats a des chances
d'être prolongée si le gouvernement
espagnol est capable de proposer un
calendrier de travail pour examiner nos
revendications
s'il n'a à offrir une fois de plus que
des propositions de réinsertion sociale
pour les membres de l' eta
nous allons vers un réel échec après
l'arrestation de yushu ternira membres
de thé à il ya dix jours le numéro deux
du gouvernement espagnol se dit prêt à
représenter felipe gonzalez à la table
des négociations au moment où les
slogans évoque la paix on peut parler
d'une évolution
à trois semaines de la date officielle
du retrait des troupes soviétiques
d'afghanistan la résistance qui
n'acceptait aucune trêve politique
accentue sa pression sur les principales
villes du pays dont la capitale kaboul
et les soviétiques à la manière des
américains à la fin de la guerre du
vietnam ont organisé un véritable pont
aérien pour assurer le ravitaillement en
denrées essentielles des habitants
assiégés gilles rabin
kaboul la famine qui n'a plus ni pain ni
sucre ni celle plus d'essence plus de
bois de chauffage kaboul dans la neige
le froid et le rationnement 200 g de
pain seulement par jour et par personne
kaboul la panique qui a compris que le
gouvernement pro soviétique ne
survivrait pas longtemps au départ des
soldats de l'armée rouge kaboul assiégé
par une résistance afghane qui changent
de tactique n'attaque plus les convois
militaires soviétiques mais assiègent
les grandes villes pour les affamés pour
desserrer l'étau et tenter de casser le
blocus des villes l'aviation soviéto
afghane bombardent tous les jours les
positions des moudjahidine sans
véritables résultats pour casser le
blocus
moscou a monté à la hâte ce pont aérien
alimentaire comment partir sans trahir
ce reportage de la télévision soviétique
est là pour attester que les russes
n'abandonnent pas leurs frères afghans
ni leurs alliés
aujourd'hui pourtant les régiments celui
tic repartent clandestinement dans le
plus grand secret et c'est la résistance
afghane qui comptabilise les retraits
douze mille soldats de l'armée rouge
sont rentrés en urss
cette semaine le ministre les affaires
étrangères français monsieur roland
dumas en visite officielle en israël
depuis ce matin et déjà une première
rencontre avec le premier ministre
israélien monsieur itzhak shamir pour
tenter de le convaincre de la nécessité
d'une négociation internationale et
d'une discussions directes avec les
palestiniens de la lp sur place notre
envoyé spécial martine laroche-joubert
d'abord la mémoire celle des juifs tués
pendant l'holocauste
roland dumas ce matin à jérusalem au
monument de yad vashem une cérémonie à
l'écart de toute politique en hommage à
son père georges dumas exécutés par les
allemands pour avoir sauvé des juifs
comme simone l'attend pour chaque juste
un nom juif qui les a aidés on plante
ici un arbre ce sont les justes parmi
les nations ces personnes a fait
nombreuses
je vous remercie
l'après-midi la politique rencontre avec
le président herzog
le ministre des affaires étrangères
moshe arens et bien sûr qu'ils savent
shamir le premier ministre une évidence
j'ai eu une conversation très
approfondie sur l'état d'esprit des
dirigeants israéliens
dans la conjoncture internationale
actuelle je dirais même la volonté que
j'ai rencontrées par tous donc de
prendre des initiatives qui iront dans
le sens de la paix c'est une volonté qui
se dégage des protestations que j'ai pu
vouloir la paix tout en maintenant ses
positions pas de conférences
internationales mais des négociations
directes sans loyauté
c'est toute la difficulté l'acolyte iv
sac souvenir en tout cas la visite de
roland dumas aura peut-être permis
d'adoucir l'amertume d'israël après les
récentes victoires diplomatique de
yasser arafat
côté palestinien roland dumas rencontrer
en fin de journée quelques personnalités
dont le maire de bethléem
elias fred enfants sont prévues au
programme à mi chemin entre la politique
et les faits divers en belgique une
semaine après la disparition mystérieuse
de l'ancien premier ministre paul vanden
boeynants la police est de plus en plus
perplexe est inquiète aucune piste
sérieuse pas de nouvelles d'éventuels
ravisseurs transportons-nous maintenant
au nord-est de l'italie à la frontière
autrichienne depuis la fin de la
première guerre mondiale la région du
haut adige et rattaché officiellement à
l'italie sous forme de province autonome
est depuis 70 ans maintenant tous les
efforts dit agnel italianisation de la
population ont échoué la preuve vous
allez l'avoir dès la première image de
ce reportage réalisé par valérie
fournioux et france brice regarde
ces habitants du sun times sont italiens
et pourtant comme tous les dimanches
matin c'est ainsi qu'il se présente
devant dieu en tenue traditionnelle du
tyrol
nous sommes au coeur du haut adige cette
province annexé en 1919 conquête
italienne sur l' empire austro-hongrois
lors de la première guerre mondiale est
depuis 70 ans dans les campagnes dans
les villes de culture s'affrontent la
langue officielle est certes l'italien
mais toute la province pense en allemand
en autrichien les deux tiers de la
population se bat pour garder leurs
racines leur langue et leur culture
chaque ville chaque rue chaque objet on
de nom l'un allemand l'autre italiens
les plus extrémistes comme ceux du parti
mais bon tu en appelle même à l'onu
en se référant à la constitution des
droits de l'homme pour le droit à
l'autodétermination des peuples
pechstein zwei frites aran dassetto rôle
les il n'y a aucun doute le sud-tyrol
peut vivre indépendant avec le soutien
de l'autriche qui est notre modèle est à
livre p ivre et celle spécifique nous
voulons l'autodétermination c'est notre
droit est la seule solution pour arriver
à cette indépendance feront elles frei
stadt secteur rôle et vac l'ofc où
l'engagement d'une minorité de tyrolien
son parti n'a obtenu qu'un seul siège
lors des dernières élections au
parlement du haut adige une province au
statut particulier en italie
ce parlement est autonome depuis 1971
les suds tyrolien sont fiers de cette
différence elles marquent leur
détachement de l'italie et comme pour
mieux la firme et ils exposent leurs
traditions cette confrérie issus du
moyen-âge au nord une fois par an ses
ancêtres tout ce chevalier d'une guerre
de l'honneur à conserver lors de la
dernière c'est à mon choisy
il était italien et se sont battus aux
côtés d'hitler
nous sommes actuellement préoccupés par
l'ingérence du gouvernement central qui
contrôle de plus en plus l'autonomie du
sud tyrol
alors nous considérons que cette
autonomie notre autonomie est en péril
et sont calmes aux cerises thomson corp
dénis rooms boeuf ou plus bruno aux
sports président de cette confrérie
s'affichant libéral le parti dont il est
le leader obtenu 35 sièges au parlement
régional
il est majoritaire dans la province face
à lui le msi mouvement social italien
parti néofasciste majoritaire lui mais à
bolzano
le chef lieu de la province car côté
italien on est un peu nostalgique on
aimerait bien revivre une certaine
époque où le pouvoir de rome était plus
fort moi je considère comme mon parti
soutient que la période
1922 et 1939 1940 grâce aux accords
entre hitler et mussolini
le problème du haut adige été résolu et
aujourd'hui la situation serait
certainement meilleur si ces accords
étaient toujours appliqué
dans le haut adige quelle est la vraie
minorité celle qui s'affiche en martyr
d'une frontière qui la séparait de son
identité ou celle qui se bat pour
exister envers et contre tout dans ce
décor autrichien qui ne lui convient pas
la page mode maintenant début des
défilés aujourd'hui des collections
printemps-été 89 des grands couturiers
ce soir christian lacroix et 30
reportage de yoga grégoire et dida
légère fluide enveloppé de mousseline
femmes maharaja ou romantique à
l'anglais c'est la femme femme
transparence coquine ligne près du corps
longueur au genou à la cheville
quelquefois au mollet suivant l'humeur
d'ailleurs tricolore pour bicentenaire
et glamour pour le soir belle matière
pour bell du soir une collection
féminine est radieuse ch et aux rentes
ligne trapèze robes au genou pantalons
larges le citron et fuchsia les couleurs
fétiches de christian lacroix nostalgie
des anciennes colonies influence de
lorient qui nous fait rêver tout comme
ses robes
délicates broderies pour ce punch ou en
organza une collection romantique et
exotique tout à la fois qui le temps
d'un défilé nous fait voyager dans les
pays lointains la suite dans les jours
qui viennent le premier ministre du
québec robert bourassa bien d'arriver à
paris pour tenter de relancer les
relations économiques entre paris et la
belle province en effet malgré l'unité
de langues
la france n'est que le cinquième
fournisseur et le 6e clients du québec
dans le même temps car je vais vous
parler d'autre chose sur le plan
culturel le chanteur français renault a
entrepris une tournée là-bas au québec
qui nous a semblé intéressant de savoir
si le français de renault était apprécié
par nos cousins reportage de nos
confrères québécois andré chouinard paul
landry réalisation pire est fort
regardez ça vaut la peine
bienvenue dans mon tipi ce soir visage
pâle déterré hache de guerre contre gros
combinés et fumé calumet de la paix avec
vous
le parler
renaud séchan d'un nettement
l'impression d'être chez lui au québec
confiant efforts de l'affection qu'il a
du public ils tirent sur tout ce qui
bouge ici il est documenté au point
d'étonner
herbert léonard non mais la prochaine
fois qu'il vient ici gardez le et voici
comment renault cite un ministre
québécois présente la chanson sur madame
thatcher il dit en fait la véritable
grosse maudite anglaise dire on devient
[ __ ] si bien souvent être les pères
renault est connu au québec depuis 1995
comment perçoit-il les québécois qu'il
ya un titre qui disait on juge un peuple
à ses chauffeurs de taxi mais assez vers
son café son café parisien et j'avais un
texte les parisiens sont pas assez
agressif dans l'ensemble je généralise
et si les gens sont chaleureux et son du
coeur ils se sont ouverts et son
attachement à l'importance aux il
décortique paillis analyse pas avec le
langage attachement l'importance aux
mots quand il parle il parle peu mais ça
m'a dit soit plus droit au coeur et les
québécois québécoise eux qu'en
pense-t-il
oui bonjour les français font pas
gonnehem renault parce qu'ils me disent
qu'ils parlent
mise à part gilles vigneault renault est
le seul chansonnier a osé se prononcer
sur les problèmes linguistiques et
détendre avec nuance la loi 101 qui
protège la langue française d'amérique
dire que je suis en même temps farouche
défenseur de l'esprit de la loi 101 qui
en même temps j'aime pas les oies et
puis en même temps j'aime les minorités
et puis donc je sais je sais que malgré
tout il ya une minorité anglophone au
québec
j'ai pas envie qui ces gens là soient
rejetés dans un ghetto c'est en france
mon public apprend que j'étais applaudir
une loi je vous dis
lamy se remuent reçu du versant
autour d'arthur
renault le pouf il est maintenant
presque un chanteur québécois
et lorsqu'on lui demande s'il aimerait
vivre ici maison à montréal et je suis
un petit peu citoyens de ce pays
une façon je me sens citoyen du monde
oiseaux plantes menaces en tout temps
d'une branche
je tire sur le ici andré chouinard à
québec
merci andré le résultat du tiercé pour
terminer ce journal du tiercé et du kart
et d'ailleurs qui s'est couru cet après
midi à vincennes 10,5 17 c'est l'ordre
d'arrivée beau tiercé 28 1397 francs 50
centimes pour ce qui concerne le quarté
le xiii qui a porté chance aujourd'hui
241 1534 francs est toujours 20 centimes
voilà ce journal est terminée tout de
suite après les prévisions météo avec
josé blanc lapierre ensuite le film le
policier du dimanche soir et puis aux
alentours de 23h30 philippe gassot pour
les toutes dernières informations et
notamment les résultats de l'élection
législative partielle de marseille avec
monsieur bernard tapie et guy teissier
et puis bien sûr demain matin télématin
6h45 antenne de 12h à 13h et puis à 20h
vous retrouverez ici même hervé claude
quant à moi je serai vraiment ravi de
vous retrouver samedi prochain pour tout
le week-end au revoir à la semaine
prochaine